el denominado convoy de la libertad que
nació en canadá ha trascendido fronteras
adecuándose la coyuntura como explicó en
france 24 el analista yoma dice no haber
una difusión del movimiento y del
descontento yo creo que hay una
desconfianza hacia las instituciones
tanto los partidos los sindicatos
incluso la autoridad científica en
muchos países del mundo entonces es
posible que veamos versiones locales de
ese movimiento pero claramente con
diferencias pero que hay detrás
el movimiento superó a su primer
organizador el sector camionero
canadiense ahora varios políticos
republicanos estadounidenses grupos
supremacistas blancos y personajes
influyentes de la derecha a nivel
mundial se han tomado la lucha como
propia
qué papel han jugado en las redes
sociales la causa de su popularización
no se puede explicar sin las plataformas
digitales según el portal estadounidense
político tan solo entre el 22 de enero y
el 5 de febrero más de 7000
publicaciones en facebook mencionaban al
llamado convoy de la libertad generando
decenas de miles de reacciones telegram
se ha convertido en el núcleo de las
manifestaciones es allí donde se
coordinan los siguientes pasos del
movimiento el miércoles su grupo en
francia tenía más de 23 mil miembros
cómo se financia los crowdfunding han
sido la base de su financiación que ha
tomado enormes dimensiones
el portal code font me eliminó la
donación colectiva denominada como
freedom convoy 2022 que recaudó casi 10
millones de dólares asegurando que
devolvería el dinero pero la decisión
fue criticada incluso por el gobernador
de la florida brand de santis
obtener 9 millones en donaciones
enviadas por apoyar a camioneros y
donarlos a causas de su propia elección
un hecho que no ha detenido el
movimiento que siguió con su recaudación
de millones en la plataforma give and go
que ve como las cifras aumentan ahora
ahora